[Música]
piden pena de muerte para nicolás cruz
acusado de perpetrar el ataque contra
una escuela en florida en 2018 que dejó
17 personas muertas pero será aprobada
por el jurado de forma unánime cruz se
enfrentaría a la cadena cargada
polémica en méxico por la construcción
del tren maya un megaproyecto del
gobierno en la península de yucatán
cuyas obras representan un daño grave
para el medio ambiente según una ong que
busca detener la construcción
argumentando que se reanudó sin un
permiso judicial
en colombia la jurisdicción especial
para la paz organizó actos de
reconocimiento de militares por haber
ejecutado a civiles inocentes de forma
extrajudicial cara a cara las víctimas
pudieron expresar su dolor ante los
responsables
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en eeuu porque la
fiscalía pidió pena de muerte para
nicolás cruz el autor del ataque a una
escuela secundaria en parkland florida
en 2018 y en el que murieron 14
estudiantes y 3 empleados la petición se
dio durante el primer día de audiencias
por el caso y si solo un miembro del
jurado se opone la solicitud del fiscal
será descartada y nicolás cruz será
condenado a cadena perpetua
lágrimas dentro de la sala durante el
primer día de juicio por el tiroteo
masivo en una escuela de parto la
florida en el banquillo nicolás cruz de
23 años autor del asesinato de 14
estudiantes y 3 empleados escolares
el acusado en este caso se ha declarado
culpable de 17 cargos de asesinato en
primer grado en un procedimiento
anterior las sentencias apropiadas para
el delito de homicidio en primer grado
ya sea cadena perpetua sin posibilidad
de libertad condicional o muerte
la fiscalía ya pidió que el castigo sea
la pena de muerte por una masacre fría
calculada y premeditada chules war
y es más
tres días antes de esta masacre el
acusado en este caso hizo un vídeo con
su teléfono y esto fue lo que dijo
hola mi nombre es nik voy a hacer el
próximo tirador escolar de 2018
mi objetivo es al menos 20 personas con
un ar-15 y algunas rondas trazadoras a
hacer un gran evento y cuando me vean en
las noticias sabrán quién soy todos van
a morir
yo
el 14 de febrero de 2018 el joven de
entonces 19 años regresó a la escuela de
secundaria la que había sido expulsado
meses antes por problemas de conducta y
abrió fuego con un rifle semiautomático
durante casi seis minutos después salió
del edificio sin ser detectado y fue
arrestado poco más tarde caminando por
una calle residencial parlan fue uno de
los tiroteos masivos más mortíferos en
eeuu nunca antes un tirador masivo en el
país había sobrevivido para enfrentar
los cargos ahora vamos hasta méxico
donde la ong internacional greenpeace
realizó una protesta pacífica para
detener las obras del tren maya un
proyecto que planea extenderse en el
sureste del país por toda la riviera
maya- la organización aseguró que las
construcciones se reanudaron sin el
permiso judicial que está pendiente y el
cual determinará si las obras
representan un daño grave para el medio
ambiente con pablo lo que nos cuenta más
un grito de auxilio por la naturaleza
con un inmenso salvavidas extendió en
una selva de playa del carmen la ong
ambientalista internacional greenpeace
realizó una protesta pacífica para
frenar las obras del tramo 5 del llamado
tren maya que planea extenderse por la
riviera maya
a partir de las denuncias de ciudadanos
de activistas de habitantes de aquí de
la región pues vimos que se estaban
reanudando las obras del tramo 5 y es
por eso que greenpeace realizó trabajo
en campo para verificar que
efectivamente estaban ocurriendo y
reanudando las obras a una de las
agrupaciones que denunció la
reactivación de las obras sin el permiso
judicial fue el movimiento ambientalista
sálvame del tren quien el pasado 5 de
julio publicó un comunicado invitando a
la población a detener el deterioro de
la selva que se enteren que el segundo
pulmón más importante de latinoamérica y
una de las reservas de agua dulce más
importantes del mundo si no exigimos de
forma colectiva proteger nuestro futuro
el tren maya ha sido uno de los
proyectos insignia del presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador que
propuso invertir 10 mil millones de
dólares en alrededor de 1500 kilómetros
de vía férrea en los estados de chiapas
tabasco campeche yucatán y quintana roo
ubicados en el sureste del país esta es
la segunda vez que una organización
ambientalista internacional realiza una
protesta pacífica pidiendo que se
desmonten las construcciones en la selva
vamos a colombia este lunes y martes en
la ciudad de valledupar ubicada en el
caribe colombiano la jurisdicción
especial para la paz organiza actos de
reconocimiento de militares por haber
ejecutados civiles inocentes de forma
extrajudicial las víctimas pudieron
expresar su dolor ante los responsables
más detalles con luís muñoz
un nuevo reconocimiento ante la
jurisdicción especial para la paz
militares de colombia ejecutaron a
civiles inocentes de forma extrajudicial
son los conocidos como 'falsos
positivos' no eran guerrilleros
solo eran hombres
o jóvenes que apenas iban a comenzar sus
proyectos de vida
donde sólo estamos asesinando a personas
inocentes que no tenían nada que ver con
el conflicto armado este último
reconocimiento hace referencia a hechos
de la primera década de 2000 en el
batallón la popa de valledupar en el
caribe colombiano para este auto la
jurisdicción especial para la paz imputó
a dos coroneles y trece militares por
127 asesinatos y desapariciones forzadas
sin embargo los dos altos mandos
responsables no aceptaron los cargos y
no estuvieron presentes en la primera de
las dos audiencias las autoridades
indígenas de los pueblos wiwa y kankuamo
denunciaron que el número sería incluso
mayor porque los encargados de velar de
promocionar y cuidar y respetar los
derechos humanos hicieron lo contrario
el ejército colombiano presentó
sistemáticamente en todo el país a
civiles como guerrilleros fue en el
marco de la seguridad democrática
impulsada por el gobierno del
expresidente álvaro uribe con el
objetivo de acabar con la guerrilla los
militares actuaban bajo presión para
presentar buenos números a cambio
recibían recompensas económicas y viajes
la jurisdicción especial para la paz
surgió en 2016 fruto del acuerdo entre
el estado y la extinta guerrilla de las
farc si los reconocimientos son
considerados suficientes por el tribunal
y las víctimas los acusados podrían
obtener penas restaurativas que no
conlleven prisión y un nuevo motín se
registró en una cárcel de ecuador
dejando tres personas muertas según
anunciaron las autoridades
penitenciarias ellos agregaron que el
incidente que se produjo en una prisión
en la ciudad de santo domingo se debió a
una disputa en la que otras dos personas
resultaron heridas se trata de la misma
cárcel en la que el pasado mes de mayo
44 personas murieron durante un
amotinamiento este es el último de una
serie de episodios de violencia
carcelaria en el país que padece
hacinamiento en estos centros
penitenciarios
y cerramos en argentina porque se
cumplieron este lunes 28 años del
atentado a la amia la agencia mutual
israelita que dejó 85 fallecidos
familiares de las víctimas realizaron
una manifestación en buenos aires
exigiendo justicia ya que al día de hoy
ninguno de los culpables ha sido
capturado o enjuiciado las
investigaciones han apuntado a irán e
incluso a expresidentes hasta ahora sin
ningún resultado
andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
28 años del atentado a la asociación
mutual israelita argentina amia el acto
terrorista más mortífero de la historia
del país que causó la muerte a 85
personas y dejó unas 100 heridas a las
953 del 18 de junio de 1994 un camión
cargado de explosivos estalló frente al
edificio y este lunes cientos de
personas se reunieron para conmemorar a
las víctimas
a 28 años de tu ausencia cristiana
y me queda de voz
me queda de voz la historia
la que te apasiona das estudiabas y
nuestra historia la que anida y disfruta
la amia aún pide justicia tras años de
impunidad cómo explicar que en 28 años
no se ha podido atrapar siquiera uno de
los múltiples responsables de semejante
atrocidad que los canallas miserables y
asesinos de 85 personas siguen
disfrutando de su vida diaria paseando
por el mundo con total libertad como se
explica tanta impunidad
en febrero de 2019 un tribunal argentino
absolvió al ex presidente carlos menem
que gobernó el país entre 1989 y 1999
acusado de conspirar para desviar las
investigaciones sobre el atentado el ex
mandatario siempre negó una mala
actuación en 2015 horas antes de
comparecer ante el legislativo apareció
muerto el fiscal alberto nisman conocido
por intentar exponer acusaciones contra
el entonces presidenta cristina
fernández por supuestamente encubrir la
participación de irán en el atentado
tribunales argentinos se atribuyen los
hechos a hezbollah pero no se ha juzgado
a nadie en relación con esta teoría el
viernes pasado el presidente argentino
alberto fernández recibió a las
autoridades de la amia y ratificó su
compromiso por el esclarecimiento de los
hechos así que es informativo en falso
24 gracias por acompañarnos continúen
con toda nuestra programación
[Música]